achraf benbrahim hauteur de l'emprise
enquête au coeur de la djihad aux
sphères aux éditions le mieux à chf raf
benbrahim merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt france alors le profil de la
saillance dessine il se dit donc
tunisiens en situation irrégulière en
france est arrivée début octobre via
l'île de lampedusa
son cheminement que traduit-il soir à ce
stade comme l'a bien l'a rappelé le
procureur ricard c'est qu'on n'en sait
pas grand chose
toutefois pour l'instant il n'y a pas de
revendications sur les réseaux sociaux
et encore moins sur les canaux
télégramme de l'état islamique n'est de
al qaïda et a finalement il correspond
un peu au profil du jeune pakistanais
qui a essayé de mener une attaque dans
les anciens locaux de charlie hebdo à
savoir qu'il prétend agir seul que il
n'a pas forcément un soutien en tout cas
une logistique d'un mouvement djihadiste
derrière lui et que par conséquence son
geste relève de l'initiative personnelle
pour moi ça me semble peu probable parce
que cette théorie du loup solitaire
je l'expliqué dans mon livre ne tient
pas on n'agit pas de la sorte kita à
mettre sa vie en danger
simplement par vocation personnelle
c'est motivé par une idéologie c'est à
dire que cette idéologie et bien elle a
été transmise il a été influencé
il a un but donc on ne peut pas parler
de nos solitaire je pense que les
prochaines heures seront décisives pour
en savoir un peu plus mais moi ce qui me
ce qui me ce qui m'interpelle
si vous voulez c'est que nous avons de
la france actuellement connaît de plus
en plus de cas comme celui ci c'est à
dire que c'était pas forcément vous
mangez a dit ce qui est derrière mais
c'est un fanatisme personnel qui
n'attend pas d'être motivé d'être
embrigadé par un mouvement djihadiste
pour passer à l'acte il y avait eu des
appels
il ya quelques jours à s'en prendre aux
églises
notamment ils auraient pu entendre cet
appel est seul à les commettre
quand vous dites que vous ne croyez pas
au loup solitaire ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire que derrière il ya tout de
même un minimum de logistique
oui il faut qu' il faut que votre
audience compris une chose c'est que les
mouvements djihadistes pourquoi ils sont
extrêmement efficaces sur sur la toile
et sur la communication numérique c'est
parce que ce sont des gens qui sont
rompus à la clandestinité
or c'est bien parce seul vecteur qu'ils
arrivent encore à communiquer depuis la
perte de des territoires dans la zone
irako syrienne
par conséquent synagogue église tout ce
qui peut en tout cas leur eurent
présenté une symbolique pour finalement
terrorisé est une cible de choix
alors on le voit bien dans ces attaques
terroristes il ya deux types de profils
il ya il ya les réfugiés qui arrivent
sur le territoire comme cela pourrait
être le cas comme l'expliquait le
procureur antiterroriste on va attendre
de voir la suite de l' enquête vient
aussi les frères kouassi qui ont grandi
1 sur le territoire français est ce que
ce sont des profils similaires ou alors
finalement leur histoire ne se
ressemblent pas du tout non pour moi il
ya une grande différence
les frères kouachi ce sont des personnes
qui ont été énormes et en territoire
français qui ont grandi en territoire
français et qui ont des références qu
culturel purement français là on a
affaire à quelqu'un qui apparemment met
les pieds pour la première fois en
europe donc par conséquent ce n'est pas
du tout les mêmes modes de vie de
culture de perception politique
je voudrais aussi préciser une chose
pour pour les ide pour les auditeurs qui
nous écoutent c'est que les trois
jihadistes français les plus dangereux
sur sur cette dernière décennie
s'appelle adrien gyal thomas balmes ans
fabien cahen donc ce n'est pas vraiment
une question d'origine ou de lieu de
donner sens c'est vraiment une question
d'idéologie et de motivation aujourd'hui
simple idéologie sur le territoire
français quel est quel est son état
alors c'est un état je dirais qui est
lacunaire
pourquoi parce que le pouvoir
d'attractivité cave et l'état islamique
c'était de dire eh bien nous avons un
califat nous avons un territoire à
défendre et par conséquent vous devez
nous y rejoint leurs cartes et de votre
obligation de vivre dans un dans un
territoire islamique cette attractivité
là forcément depuis la défaite de l'état
islamique de façon militaire est diminué
en revanche l'idéologie notamment pour
les sympathisants de la première heure
reste la même vous avez des viviers de
recrutement qui se maintiennent
non pas parce que il y à une croissance
de cette probable propagation mais parce
que vous avez des convaincus qu'ils qui
sont soit encore sur le territoire
national et qui n'ont pas pu justement
rejoindre ces organisations la soie qui
sont en prison et qui vont sortir voir
qu'ils sont déjà même sorti donc le
danger reste extrêmement grand toutefois
l'état islamique et d'autres mouvements
djihadistes vu les restrictions qu'il y
a de la part des gars femmes vont avoir
de plus en plus de mal à recruter de
nouveaux sympathisants
mais les sympathisants les primes aux
sympathisants qui sont convaincus de la
logique djihadistes évidemment reste
très dangereux et sur le terrain
qu'est-ce qu'il en mai notamment sur le
territoire
français élu prosélytisme qui est très
fort aujourd'hui notamment dans
certaines zones dans certains quartiers
je pense pas qu'il s'agit de territoires
parce que si vous regardez encore une
fois le profil de ceux qui sont partis
et de ceux qui ont commis des attentats
sur le territoire français ils viennent
de partouche je pense pas que ce soit
une question de territoire c'est une
pièce montagne par exemple dans des
coins isolés en tout cas oui c'est ce
que je dis c'est à dire que une les
jihadistes n'ont pas besoin d'être dans
les quartiers à majorité immigrées
pour convaincre de leur logique c'est
pour ça que j'ai expliqué que les frire
klein par exemple avait grandi à
toulouse thomas barnouin qui a été
capturé par les kurdes il ya de cela
deux ans vient d'une famille de
résistants étaient scolarisés dans
l'éducation
je crois protestante ou catholique
donc c'est vraiment une question de
conviction et de et de logique
jihadistes est ce qu'aujourd'hui il ya
un changement de logique c'est à dire
que avant on voyait partir des personnes
vers des zones de guerre on pense
notamment à la syrie est ce
qu'aujourd'hui à une dynamique qui
s'inverse avec ces personnes qui veulent
venir faire la guerre sur le territoire
français avant même que l'état islamique
pertes
son dernier réduit sur la zone dira qu
syrienne alors moi j'avais en 2016
interviewé le djihadiste rachid casting
soupçonné d'être l'instigateur de
plusieurs attentats notamment celui de
saint-etienne du rouvray que ça ne
servait à plurien finalement de venir en
irak que cyrielle parce que les
frontières étaient fermés parce que
n'était plus en capacité de leur fournir
la logistique nécessaire pour participer
aux combats
par conséquent il faut attaquer sur
place donc avant même d'avoir perdu ces
derniers réduits territoriaux l'état
islamique appelé à frapper les pays
mécréants et particulièrement la france
au sein même du territoire pour terminer
en quelques mots on a entendu beaucoup
de réactions politiques qui appelait à
l'action sans attendre de temps selon
vous qui connaissez parfaitement cette
gen zo ce faire qu'est-ce qui serait
efficace pour lutter contre ces
terroristes pour moi trois choses la
première c'est de ne pas s'emballer ce à
garder la tête froide 900 ans
un mouvement qui est qui est récent et
toutes les démocraties auront affronté
ce phénomène la deuxième c'est donner
plus de moyens notamment aux plateformes
de signalement comme pharos et puis
troisièmement doter les personnels des
services de l'ordre de moyens de
compréhension vraiment logique je pense
pas que l'ags la guéguerre entre
services de renseignement et puis
surtout entre politiques interposés
servent à quelque chose
il faut garder la tête froide c'est le
seul conseil que moi je peux donner de
ma modeste opposition
merci beaucoup en tout cas achraf
benbrahim d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
auteur de l'emprise enquête au coeur de
la dgi à dos faire